Senator John McCain represented Arizona
but New Hampshire played a special role
in his political career McCain held 114
town halls across the Granite State
during his presidential campaign in 2000
John Dickerson covered McCain in the
lead-up to his historic victory in that
year's New Hampshire primary John
recently returned to the New Hampshire
town of Peterborough to hear McCain's
confidants reminisce about the Senators
remarkable political story he joins us
now from Mishawaka Indiana where later
today he'll interview former President
Jimmy Carter John good morning thanks
Nora that's right I'll talk to President
Carter
I'll ask him about Senator McCain you
know as you heard so many times Senator
McCain in New Hampshire talked about
devoting yourself to a cause greater
than yourself interest well that's what
President Carter is here at Habitat for
Humanity there is an army of volunteers
around me dedicating themselves to just
that what made covering Senator McCain
in 2000 so extraordinary is that he was
all open everything was on display and
yet behind it were classic American
values McCain was an independent called
a maverick breaking down the status quo
and for the moment in time he won in New
Hampshire for the merry band surrounding
him and the senator it was nothing short
of magical we came here for one of our
first town hall meetings in the basement
and served ice cream in hopes that we
could get a few people out and we got 13
but then the last one we had the night
before the primary was jam-packed with
people out the door what happened here
at the Town Hall in Peterborough New
Hampshire is a metaphor for John
McCain's 2000 presidential campaign
Dupree ran the New Hampshire Republican
Party at the time Mike Dennehy was
McCain's campaign manager this was our
campaign sign for 2000 it really
Illustrated the entire campaign from
start to finish starting so small and
ending up with people busting through
the doors I can beat Al Gore like a drum
Senator John McCain
Leslie campaigned across the state on a
bust aptly named the Straight Talk
Express it's 1999 give me a sense of
where the Republican Party is in the
presidential race wide open I just
remember we had lots of candidates the
field of candidates included Elizabeth
Dole Dan Quayle Pat Buchanan and a
president's son Texas Governor George W
Bush our first poll here in New
Hampshire showed me at 2% with a 5%
margin of error what that could mean is
3% actually were against me the Arizona
senator often asked the crowd for
sympathy because we have so little water
in Arizona the trees chase the dogs who
all think of yourself as sort of David
and Goliath versus George W Bush yeah
yes George W Bush had everything going
for him so it was difficult to get
anyone's attention but what we did get
was John McCain's time which was the
most meaningful McCain was a different
kind of politician he may have kept tugs
of hand sanitizer on the bus but he
shook every hand took every question
questions yes ma'am you go I like
Republicans Democrats libertarians
vegetarians egalitarians yeah there'd be
people who would be a little belligerent
and yell and interrupt and John would be
very good he'd say if you just stop
yelling I'm gonna call on you next and
we can have our debate I thank you for
your question your comment and he'd take
on these people and after a couple
minutes to say okay I'm clearly not your
candidate I think we're done and now you
need to sit down so others could have a
chance it it was great entertainment
I'm cold winter nights McCain's candor
was on display during those long
stretches on the road I'll be glad to
beat the crap out of President Clinton
even and perhaps most especially when
reporters were on the bus Steve it feels
like this campaign in 2000 the Straight
Talk Express and the fact that Senators
in the center of a horseshoe of
reporters talking as near as we could
tell constantly that feels like an age
before the Internet what would be
possible today no wouldn't it I saw John
do this on the bus a couple times
he made some comment that I could say
whoa that will not look good as a
headline he goes in does the town hall
meeting he comes out and John Weaver
talks to reporters and goes
Senator McCain would like to revise that
statement a little bit and back then
people cross out what he'd said before
and took down the revised statement and
it worked did he have any flaws none of
oh oh he's out there to get Bill Clinton
opponent seized on McCain's temper
calling him senator hot hand
McCain's team prepared him for criticism
during this closed-door strategy session
filmed by 60 minutes well you know that
really makes me mad in the 2000 New
Hampshire primary McCain beat George W
Bush by an astounding 18 points I think
there's a feeling amongst the
establishment that we might have
interfered with the coronation like
what's the political legacy of John
McCain he put the town hall meeting on
the map John McCain just made
interacting people giving answers to
questions the legacy of a presidential
campaign in New Hampshire
I want the presidency in the best way
not the worst way after a blistering
victory McCain went on to lose in South
Carolina but for a moment in time the
insurgent took on the establishment and
won America loves heroes John McCain's
legitimate hero and I know he annoys a
lot of people in his party I think
sometimes he enjoys it a little bit too
much but I think the American people
respect the fact that John McCain's
gonna tell you what he thinks even if it
makes you madder than hell and you can
disagree with him but you can't question
his patriotism or his service there have
been a lot of questions of whether that
anyone will pick up the mantle after
John McCain there was no one else like
him but his message in New Hampshire and
throughout his political life was that
the things that gave him sustenance in
Hanoi for five-and-a-half years and all
throughout his career were available to
all Americans duty courage honor
discipline and love of country those
values are still open to all of us and
that was McCain
biggest message to those audiences that
found him so compelling in 2000 and 2008
John Dickerson thank you John
extraordinary life on an extraordinary
career